sigh up car Chester lino Dyson over says
BMWs 2 Series Coupe a runs in a
competitive back alley and Daimler have
compacts with more than 185 kilowatts of
power but the 230 eyes 2 litre
4-cylinder turbo churns out 252 horses
or nearly 188 kilowatts so is the BMW
the predator or the prey rival Mercedes
a250 sport offers 25 kilowatts less
performance but at a price that's 2,500
euros higher and Audi TT coupe a comes
closer at a difference of 16 kilowatts
it's 500 euros cheaper than the BMW -
the series 2 coupe a was already on the
market in 2014 but the 230 eye we tested
has only been around since last year it
can shoot from 0 to 100 kilometres an
hour and 5.6 seconds it tops out at 250
kilometers per hour
looking at the exterior it's no wonder
the two series Kupe zips along it's just
like a four series BMW and miniature
just not as flat or wide just about
everything in the engine compartment is
clad in plastic and discreetly screened
off but at least it looks tidy the hood
is long and sleek while the rear end is
cropped the 2 Series is a classic coupe
a the Mercedes a-class doesn't have the
same flare and the TTS looks don't quite
cut it either
the shape of the taillights is
reminiscent of the x6 the interior is
just fine
everything as it should be with clean
lines and classy workmanship but the
competitors from Ingolstadt and stood
guard can match it as a matter of course
there are plenty of dust catching shiny
surfaces in most of today's cars a
steptronic automatic transmission adds
about 2100 euros to the 230 eyes price
the Thiokol piece I know says the 2
Series takes people back to the iconic
2002 turbo in the early 70s the two-door
coupe a can keep up with the eleven
Series Porsche but then the oil crisis
knocked down the sales of gas guzzlers
the new 2 series has driver oriented
controls and a stiff suspension and is
still comfortable on long drives and the
backseat can even fit two adults our
test car has been fitted out with the M
Sport package that includes the M sports
chassis aerodynamic body styling a
leather steering wheel and sports seats
up front for an extra thirty-six hundred
euros
[Music]
the BMW 230 ice competitor Mercedes a250
sport includes these sporty add-ons for
a similar standard price outies TT
features an s-line sports package in the
same price class they all sell for
around 40,000 euros though not a bargain
the buyer gets plenty of performance and
comfort for the money
for people who don't want so much voom
but like the looks of the two series
coupe a there's the intro gasoline model
with a 100 kilowatt engine it sells for
just over 28,000 euros in subsequent
says the 230 I goes from zero to 100 and
five seconds and offers more trunk space
than a VW golf the big difference
between it and the GTI is rear-wheel
drive which means more driving fun
Methos bus
that's something neither the a-class
Mercedes or the Audi TT offer given that
in its class the BMW 2 Series Coupe a
appears to be the hunter rather than the
hunted